bonjour à tous samsung galaxy s 9 contre
l'iphone 10 je suis relativement avec
les vidéos que je vais vous faire depuis
longtemps
j'ai longtemps hésité à me dirai ce que
je fais cette vidéo est ce qu elle a un
sens oui et non j'ai déjà regardé la
vidéo de ce type sur internet et paie
final j'ai décidé de la faire pouvoir
vous en parlez vous donner mon point de
vue et vous dire qu'à mon avis la
question ne devrait pas se poser dans ce
sens mais on va quand même se la posent
et on va le faire maintenant
[Musique]
c'est indienne projet depuis quelques
temps parce qu'effectivement ce centre
est intéressant de comparer des produits
qui sont comparables
on peut bien évidemment complètement
comparer l'iphone 10 et le galaxy s 900
aucun problème qui sont de marques
différentes
très similaire sur de nombreux points il
ya certains points qui effectivement les
différencie mais si vous voulez des
leurres fondary font des produits très
haut de gammes des deux marques
je me dis que c'est toujours un petit
peu délicat
bon je vais vous expliquer pourquoi je
vois les choses comme ça parce que déjà
avant toute chose la première question
qui doit se poser lorsqu'on veut se dire
est-ce que je pars sur un iphone 10
parce que je pars sur un galaxy s 9 c
est la question de l' os de l' os et de
l'environnement en règle générale
d'ailleurs on peut étendre sa pas
forcément à l'iphone dismal iphone 8
l'iphone cet iphone 8 plus est plus et
compagnie et galaxy et suite à cette
chute nous est même plus sympa je vous
en parlais des muses en passe et des
meilleures la principale question à se
poser c'est quel environnement séduit et
dans quel environnement à ce que j'ai
mis les pieds parce qu'on sait très bien
que du point de vue d'apple
l'environnement est plutôt fermé les os
sont fermés tout est optimisé pour
fonctionner entre produit apple un peu
ouvert son extérieur mais pas énormément
dès lors que vous avez un produit apple
mieux vaut avoir la complète si vous
voulez à complète en tout cas des
produits qui sont directement
compatibles ce sera beaucoup plus facile
à faire fonctionner ensemble et vous en
tirerez tout le bénéfice
a contrario lorsque vous avez sur des
produits android vous pouvez plus
facilement mélanger un produit android
avec un autre même si samsung apps
tendance à privilégier les produits
samsung pour qu'ils fonctionnent
ensemble vous pourrait très bien avoir
un galaxy s 9 le rend compatible avec
une montre android parce que les os dans
l'absolu sont faits pour fonctionner
plus facilement ensemble
d'autant plus qu'il faut vraiment est
large à la question aujourd'hui on parle
de smartphones il faut avoir une vision
un peu plus loin deux ténors
effectivement vous dites aujourd'hui
j'aime acheter un produit tel que dans
deux ans je vais changer
qu'est ce que je vais me poser la
question de savoir ce que je vais
changer chez moi dans deux ans trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans six ans ok bien
évidemment mais on sait très bien que en
règle générale
lorsqu'on a souscrit à un os à un autre
un environnement de quinze autres ont
tendance un petit peu à rester du côté
de cette marque là un petit peu moins
pour android parce qu'effectivement ça
qu'on est sur android on peut switcher
de machines on reste quand même sous
android même si la surcouche changes
chez apple c'est relativement différents
dont il faut se poser la question de la
maison connectée des objets connectés y
avoir une vision un peu plus large une
vision comme on dirait à 360 degrés donc
ça c'est pour introduire un petit peu le
propos
ensuite la problématique on va
rencontrer
or ces deux appareils c'est que vous
avez deux appareils très haut de gamme
autant lorsque je vous faire un
comparatif entre deux produits moyen de
gamme des produits d'entrée de gamme
vous différents produits qu'on a pu déjà
voir c'est qu'effectivement un produit
va être plus fort dans un domaine
l'autre dans le domaine c'est le choix
du constructeur à ne pas être au top
partout donc on va effectivement se
poser la question de l'utilité d'un
produit plutôt qu'un autre par rapport à
vos besoins à vous sauf que sur des
produits très haut de gamme comme le
samsung galaxy s 9 et l'iphone 10 vous
avez des produits qui sont au top de
chaque côté alors il ya des différences
bien évidemment sont des différences
notables mais j'ai bien peur que soit
très compliqué de juger réellement de la
différence de la mesure et sur
l'utilisation quotidienne sur
utilisation courante
alors effectivement si vous êtes un vrai
amateur la photographie vous voulez
aller plus loin vous dit pour moi le s9
avec une ouverture variable avec des
superbes photos en faible luminosité
c'est vraiment ce qui me convient
pourquoi pas je suis pas sûr sur iphone
ou ipad est rendu vraiment qu'ils sont
excellents en faible luminosité
parce qu'à mon avis ça va se jouer à pas
grand chose voilà pourquoi je me suis
longuement tâter à vous faire cette
vidéo parce que de toute façon vous
aident à côté de l'autre deux produits
qui sont vraiment au top mais néanmoins
on va quand même regardé un peu ça de
plus près alors on va pas du tout
regardé la fiche technique se pencher
dans il y en a plein d'autres qui l'ont
fait sur la toile c'est pas du tout mon
propos aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je vais
vous mettre à rien dans la description
pour les voir une chaîne américaine que
j'adore austin evans qui ont fait des
super vidéo et qui a fait un super
comparatif très technique très
accessible la seule chose par contre
ceux qui vont vous parler la langue de
shakespeare
si l'anglais s'est pas votre dada vous
risquez s'offrir un petit peu si vous
parlez anglais vous allez voir la vidéo
est complète et elle est super bien fait
vous emilie en bas vous pouvez aller la
voir on va attaquer par le point central
c'est la photo et la vidéo parce que
c'est vraiment ce qui est mis en avant
par samsung au niveau de son samsung
galaxy s 9 et s9 plus l'appareil photo
réinventer c'est-à-dire un appareil
photo avec une double ouverture une
ouverture qui en mode automatique va
changer automatiquement en fonction des
conditions de luminosité de votre pièce
soit une ouverture en 2.4 son ouverture
en en points 5
ce qui fait que sur une ouverture en 1.5
l'ouverture un peu plus faible vous
allez capter beaucoup mieux la lumière
dans un environnement sombre
c'est très intéressant bien évidemment
maintenant effectivement le problème c
est ce que vous allez faire beaucoup de
photos dans un environnement vraiment
sombre et est ce que vous allez vraiment
sentir la différence par rapport à un
iphone 10 je ne suis pas sûr je trouve
que les photos en faible luminosité du
point de vue du galaxy s 9
vous avez un traitement logiciel quatre
ans un tout petit peu à lisser et on a
un tout petit peu moins de détails
c'est du point de détail mais ça a son
importance a contrario sur la n10
effectivement être capté un petit peu
moins de lumière je trouve que vous avez
plus de détails au niveau du rendu donc
chacun à un point positif chacun un
point négatif c'est pas à mon avis
vraiment là-dessus que la différence va
se faire
d'un point de vue vidéo les deux
fonctionnent très bien l'iphone 10 un
super stabilisateur
le samsung galaxy s 9 fonctionne aussi
très bien les deux films en 4k dans les
deux cas vous aurez effectivement des
très beaux rendu photo et vidéo et ni
l'un ni l'autre ne vous décevra je suis
pas sûr que vous allez utiliser les
produits à fond pour aller chercher
effectivement les moindres détails les
utiliser à fond dans leurs
retranchements
je suis pas convaincu donc si vous
voulez ce dire le galaxy ace 9 est
vraiment meilleure au niveau de la photo
l'iphone dit c'est le meilleur au niveau
de la vidéo c'est un peu problématique
parce que une fois de plus ce n'est pas
forcément des photographes
professionnels si vous l'êtes vous
n'êtes pas forcément faire des photos
avec vos smartphones donc bon il faut
garder une certaine mesure là dessus
ensuite du point de vue de l'écran pour
moi c'est vraiment le truc est
symptomatique parce que vous avez de
chaque côté un écran oled des écrans qui
sont fabriqués par samsung que ce soit
un cran infiniti du galaxy s 9 et s9
plus où tu sois d'écran d'iphone disque
est fabriqué par samsung display dans
les deux cas les écrans sont très très
bon apple va voir un autre traitement au
niveau de son écran pour effectivement
se différencier par rapport à samsung
dans les deux cas ça fonctionne vraiment
bien la différence maintenant ceux du
point de vue esthétique est ce que vous
préférez l'encoche que vous avez en eau
au niveau de la caméra trop d'aix de
l'iphone 10 ou est-ce que vous préférez
le côté arrondi du samsung galaxy s 9 s9
plus l'écart va vraiment ça là dessus on
n'est donc pas en train de juger un
produit par rapport à des réelles
problématiques par rapport au fait
quelqu'un qui est vraiment meilleur que
l'autre on est en train de parler de
goût personnel je pourrais vous dire
selon moi j'adore l'encoche selon moi
j'adore les bords incurvés où selon moi
je dans les deux bons le produit pour
l'instant je n'ai pas encore trouvé
celui qui a les deux mais peut-être
qu'il va arriver mais en réalité je ne
ferai que vous donnez
avis très personnel et j'ai pas du tout
avoir quelque chose d'objectif sera
hyper subjectif et sa beauté problème de
ce comparatif sur ces deux produits très
haut de gamme qui sont vraiment tous les
deux au top les deux en écran 5,8 pouces
donc ça va pas changer grand chose côté
batterie ça changera pas non plus grand
choix aux 3000 millions paire eur pour
le s9 2716 pour l'iphone 10 bon de toute
façon on parle de chiffres là au niveau
d'une batterie mais de toute façon les
os sont optimisés pour avoir des
produits pour avoir une bonne durée de
vie attention néanmoins il ya un
problème un problème majeur avec
l'iphone 10 au niveau de la batterie la
roue charge par induction et s'en va en
parler dès demain dont je vous invite à
vous abonner parce que vous allez voir
il ya un vrai vrai gros soucis au niveau
de la recharge par induction au niveau
l'iphone 10 on parle demain
du point de vue des technologies
déverrouillage des quelque chose qui
marche très très bien au niveau d'un
mapping en trois dimensions de votre
visage qui fait via la caméra trop def
du coup plus de 80 empreintes digitales
quelque chose qui marche super bien mais
de notre côté quelque chose qui marche
plutôt bien même plutôt très bien aussi
le côté sur le samsung galaxy s 9
vous avez une combinaison avec d'un côté
une reconnaissance de visage sans scan
en 3d votre visage s'accoupler à un
scanner d'iris donc ça vous reconnaît
rapidement ça les verrouille vite la
caméra trop d'absents tendance à
déverrouiller un peu plus vite mais
c'est une histoire de 4 secondes
donc ça va pas changer grand chose dans
votre utilisation après le système de
samsun me paraît moins sécurisés que
celui l'iphone 10 mais une fois de plus
on va pas aller vous piquer votre
smartphone utilisé des techniques
d'agent secret pour le déverrouiller et
pour accéder à votre contenu donc tout
pour utilisation de tout un chacun que
ce soit l'un ou que ce soit l'autre les
deux font très bien la faire alors en
plus de ça vous avez d'un côté les
animaux dgi pour apple de côté les arm
moggi pour samsung
je trouve que du point de vue détail les
animaux ji fonctionne un peu mieux que
les aérer moggi ça c'est probablement
lié avec labyrinthe roudeix avec un
mapping 3d de votre visage
ça doit se calait beaucoup mieux avoir
plus de détails donc forcément des
animaux ji qui vont être beaucoup plus
intéressant sauf que en réalité vous
verrez pas la différence
ils font même pas l'intérêt de poser
cette question point positif aussi pour
les arn moggi c'est que vous pouvez les
utiliser pour des réseaux sociaux vous
n'êtes pas comme sur apple bloquer
uniquement à l'envoi de messages ça
c'est aussi quelque chose qui pourrait
évoluer qu'on pouvait retrouver à la
table ou d'abeille ou
ici la conférence des développeurs
d'apple qui aura lieu le 4 juin prochain
d'ailleurs ça vous intéresse je vous en
parle dans cette vidéo voilà c'est
quelque chose qu'on va suivre de plus
près parce que de toute façon les
animaux jean vont être amenées à évoluer
côté performances ça se tient dans un
mouchoir de poche les deux machines sont
vraiment optimisé 4 gigas de ram 3 giga
de ram bon ça change pas grand chose
c'est dans un mouchoir de poche parce
que de toute façon les os sont optimisés
tout est optimisé n'y a pas grand
intérêt à s'arrêter sur la fiche
technique parce que de toute façon les
deux produits fonctionnent très bien et
sont tous les deux très rapides
alors un petit point positif quand même
pour le s9 ça c'est un point très très
personnelle une fois de plus c'est la
présence du port jack vous voyez
effectivement une fois de plus ça
illustre le propos c'est à dire qu'on
parle de points très personnel pour moi
il ya un vrai intérêt à ce qu'ils aient
encore un port jack parce que j'ai des
casques un peu old school que j'adore
qui ont super qualité sont j'ai pas
nécessairement envie de passer sur des
casques sans fil sur des castres en
bluetooth mais néanmoins c'est quelque
chose extrêmement personnelle là où moi
je préfère qui importe blacks
d'autres préfèreront utiliser des
casques sans fil bon là où il ya une
différence et au niveau du prix le
galaxy s 9 fait 859 euros alors que pour
avoir un iphone 10 il faut payer 1000
159 euros
et quand même une vraie différence au
point de vue là donc effectivement apple
ça se paye c'est pas nouveau ça ne
change pas il ya eu une augmentation de
prix chez samsung
entre le 28 et le s9 au niveau des prix
à la sortie le sg de coûter 2 809 euros
l'ene à 859 euros on imagine qu
effectivement avec les innovations
forcément il ya un surcoût un surcoût
qui répercutée sur l'utilisateur et ça
me paraît assez logique
on n'est pas arrivé dans les tarifs qui
sont quand même assez astronomiques un
passé les 1000 euros pour un smartphone
même si effectivement il ya galaxy note
8 qui est plus élevé l'iphone 10 août
quand même relativement cher même si
effectivement l'année prochaine les prix
risquent d'être plus abordables avec
trois nouveaux iphone qui pourrait
arriver si ça vous intéresse vous ai
fait une vidéo vous invite à les
découvrir il ya un autre point positif
le galaxy s 9 permet d'avoir une double
carte sim mais une fois de plus
fondamentalement qui a besoin d'une
double carte sim
c'est une possibilité pour les
professionnels pour avoir une carte pro
et une carte perso dans son smartphone
pour les personnes qui vont aller à
l'étranger qui vont voyager à l'étranger
ou alors qu'ils vont vivre entre deux
pays
les frontaliers il ya un intérêt à voir
deux cartes sim mais pour l'ensemble la
majorité la population
je ne pense pas que vous en ayez
réellement besoin
je ne pense pas non plus que ce soit
vraiment un point de différence fort
autre point de détail
le galaxy s 9 à une certification ip68
l'iphone 10 une certification ip67 dans
les deux cas si vous prenez de l'eau sur
vos smartphones ils résisteront très
bien vous n'êtes pas vous amuser aller
dans les grandes profondeurs à l'essec
demi-heure pour tester vraiment la
certification à fond les pauvres
utilisation courante vous ne sentirez
pas la différence
donc c'est un petit peu tout le problème
si vous voulez que j'ai rencontrés
lorsque j'ai voulu faire cette vidéo je
me suis dit ok il faut qu'on compare des
points qui sont comparables il faut qu
on vraiment il ya une vraie différence
et qui est un vrai sens je pense que la
vraie différence si vous voulez pour
choisir pour conclure entre l'iphone 10
et le samsung galaxy s 9 et es9 plus ce
n'est pas tant le produit ce n'est pas
tant la performance du produit ce n'est
pas tant la qualité de photo ni vidéo ni
rien c'est vous votre affinité aux
produits sont quelque chose
d'extrêmement subjectif quel est le
smartphone qui va vous attirer le plus
d'un point de vue esthétique
quelles sont les couleurs qui vont vous
plaire est-ce que l'on coche vous plaît
oui ou non est ce que le bords arrondis
vous plaît oui ou non dont typiquement
cette vidéo vous aidera pas vous faire
un avis et vous dire c'est vraiment cela
qu'il faut que j'achète parce que celui
à une meilleure non les deux sont très
bons on en train de comparer deux bêtes
de compet de super smartphone et en plus
de ça il importe qu'il faut prendre en
compte c'est que apple et son iphone 10
au 4ème trimestre 2010 est samsung a
présenté son galaxy s 9 et s9 plus au
premier trimestre 2010 8
entre les deux il ya quand même quelques
mois des cas on imagine que samsung a
affiné sa copie par rapport aux annonces
qui ont été faites tout au début par
apple même si effectivement ils n'ont
pas changé la face du produit ils ont dû
affiné malgré tout leur copie pour
arriver avec un produit qu'ils estiment
supérieure pour moi les deux sont très
bons et vous allez voir que d'ici
quelques mois
apple va réagir avec trois nouveaux
produits avec des nouveaux iphone et là
où certains vous diront tout de suite le
galaxy s 9 est supérieur à l'iphone 10
parce que c'est parce que ça dans
quelque temps à vous dira tient l'iphone
10 de 2018 ou l'iphone de 2018 sera
supérieure au galaxy s 9 et ce plan
parce qu'il arrive après qu'il a eu un
peu plus de développement et que le
concurrent d'en face a tenu compte de ce
qu'a fait l'autre pour corriger sa copie
mais rassurez vous dans l'absolu si vous
achetez un galaxy s 9 si vous achetez un
iphone disent vous ne serez pas des
suppôts conclure à mon avis à trois
points essentiels le premier
et quel est le produit qui vous plaît le
plus celui que vous aimeriez à bord avec
vous celui qui vous plaît dans point de
vue esthétique et quelles sont les
couleurs qui vous plaisent le deuxième
point c'est calello sk et
l'environnement qui vous plaît est ce
que vous aimez à ios que vous êtes déjà
sur ios est ce que vous souhaitez y
rester ou alors est-ce que vous êtes sur
android est-ce que la surcouche de
samsung l'expérience vous plaît est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui vous séduit
et le troisième point c'est le prix
est-ce que 859 euros
je parle même pas de l'offre de reprise
à ce que 859 euros pour le galaxy s 9
vous convient est-ce que 1159 euros pour
l'iphone 10 je parle du prix de base sur
le la boutique d'apple vous plaît c'est
à mon sens ces trois paramètres qu'il
faut prendre en considération parce que
vous preniez là ou que vous preniez
l'autre vous ne serez pas déçus et si
vous voulez plus de détails vous invite
à les voir l'excellente vidéo de style
et valls qui vous fait vraiment un
comparatif point par point
mais bon vous allez voir au final ça n'a
pas changé la face du monde dites moi
vous ce que vous en pensez qu'elle est
le produit qui vous plaît plus quel est
votre choix entre l'iphone 10 et le
samsung galaxy s 9 même si pas du tout
des produits que vous allez acheter même
si ce n'est pas cela qui vous plaît même
si vous êtes sur une autre marque date
chez huawei honor one + 0 me et que
sais-je encore dites-moi quand même ce
que vous préférez entre ces deux
produits
et pourquoi c'est intéressant permettra
de faire un petit peu un sondage et vous
allez voir que les résultats à mon avis
vont être extrêmement subjectif marquer
ma tout son commentaire comme d'hab vous
invite à me laisser des jolies pouces
je vous invite à vous abonner parce
qu'il va y avoir toujours plus de
contenu que vous dis je vous parlais
très rapidement des problèmes liés à la
recharge par induction sur l'iphone 10
vous allez voir c'est quand même
sacrément problématique
donc restez connectés abonnez vous je
vous embrasse vous êtes les meilleurs et
je vous fais surtout les très gros
bisous à très bientôt ciao ciao
[Musique]